among the major think tanks in America
Kato is third or fourth in terms of
major media mentions we are a serious
effort to put libertarian ideas on the
table of national debate I think we do a
pretty darn good job of doing that we
have you know more than a twenty million
dollar budget we have a hundred and five
full-time employees and the Institute is
is able to put these ideas on the table
of national debate I mean the problem of
course is that the political process is
so rigged it's so oriented toward
incumbents and toward the conservative
liberal dichotomy that it's very
difficult to get these ideas implemented
to me it's just a wonderful opportunity
to be able to say this is the way it
should be and what you're doing is wrong
and and then the worst thing from my
standpoint would be to have to be in a
situation where I felt that way but I
couldn't say so I have a voice in this
Institute that is heard by the national
public and I think you know I think 30
to 40 percent of Americans are basically
libertarian I think polls show that
people I mean do you go to the
Republican Party of the Democratic Party
if you believe in civil liberties if you
are opposed to discrimination if you
believe that it's wrong for the United
States to be the world's policeman and
you we need some humility and dealing
with other nations and you believe in
dynamic market capitalism where do you
go and but I think about a third of
Americans agree with that perspective
and and so it's frustrating I think the
campaign finance laws were designed to
keep the major parties above competition
I think without those laws you'd have a
very strong Green Party that would be a
real threat to the Democrats and I think
you'd have a small el Libertarian Party
not as you know ideologically rigid as
the current Libertarian Party is that
would be real threat to the Republicans
and would attract a lot of independence
but it's it's difficult